nuevamente repasamos a la economía en
directo américa de france 24 por
supuesto con daniela landon dan y vamos
a seguir hablando de la decisión de
rusia de cortar el suministro de gas a
polonia y también a bulgaria qué tan
grave puede ser entonces del cierre de
estos grifos de casa de rusia hacia
europa bueno raúl buenos días de nuevo
pues polonia y bulgaria tienen acuerdos
de gas a largo plazo con gazprom que
expiran a finales de este año y por eso
lo están acusando de incumplir esos
contratos al cortarle el suministro pero
raúl hay otros países muy preocupados
porque pueden correr con esta misma
suerte ya que la unión europea depende
en aproximadamente un 40 por ciento del
gas ruso y se enfrentan a un dilema y es
pagar en euros y exponerse a no recibir
el gas de rusia o pagar en rublos y
exponerse a sanciones de bruselas por
incumplir los castigos de occidente esto
fue algo que acabo de decir también la
comisión europea claro es que también es
difícil como estar ahí en esa dualidad
que hago porque si necesito el gas
también pero esté dentro del bloque
comunitario pues que tanto depende
entonces europa del gas ruso gran y
bueno hace dos meses se estimaba que
había países que sólo consumían caso
ruso todo el 100% de sus suministros
provenía de rusia sin embargo los
porcentajes han venido cambiando y de
hecho esos cortes no traen problemas
graves de suministro en este momento
pues ya han venido trabajando en fuentes
alternativas y también el continente se
está dirigiendo hacia el verano y esto
hace que el gas ya no sea tan esencial
para los hogares en esta época del año
la unión europea de todas maneras quiere
reducir las importaciones de gas ruso en
dos tercios en 2022 y poner fin a su
dependencia de estos suministros rusos
mucho antes del 2030 hay sustitutos que
pueden encontrarla no europea antes de
gas ruso están analizando pero por ahora
lo que podemos decir es que alemania
podría importar gas desde gran bretaña
desde dinamarca noruega y países bajos
mientras que los países del sur de
europa como bulgaria pueden traer más
gas desde azerbaiyán a través de turquía
eeuu también se ha comprometido a
suministrar más gas licuado a partir de
este mismo año para eso los países ya
han comenzado a buscar la mano de
ampliar esa limitada capacidad de
almacenamiento de este hidrocarburo que
recordemos no es el que no se transporta
por gasoducto sino que viene de mucho
más lejos así que tiene que ser
transportado en barcazas y después pasa
por un proceso llamado regasificación
que es mucho más costoso qatar es otra
opción claro vamos a ver entonces qué va
a pasar con estas opciones y vamos a
hablar ahora de ucrania las
consecuencias que tiene este conflicto
en el territorio ucraniano por parte de
rusia pero en nuestra región américa
latina' la realidad es que estamos
analizando cómo en américa se están
sintiendo justamente esos efectos del
turno hoy es para perú cuyos
agricultores están padeciendo un fuerte
aumento en los precios de los
fertilizantes nuestro corresponsal en
lima francisco zacarías nos amplía la
información en el siguiente reportaje
desde hace más de 30 años leoncio
bizarre se dedica a la agricultura
protagónico este agricultor es uno de
los más de 2 millones de peruanos que
trabaja en el campo y que sufre el
incremento actual en el costo de los
fertilizantes ha subido todo va en
dólares en dólares por decir que antes
comprábamos un saco de abono para que 20
dólares ahora 64 dólares rusia fue el
principal proveedor de fertilizantes en
perú en 2021 más del 64,4 por ciento de
urea importada provino de la nación rusa
al igual que el 98 por ciento del
nitrato de amonio ambos son los abonos
químicos más usados gracias a nosotros
pueden comer en la ciudad
los premios agrarios calculan que van a
tener una pérdida de más del 60% en sus
ganancias y para evitar que continúe la
caída total bien al gobierno de pedro
casi o retornar a la forma de cultivo
que realizaban los incas una de las
propuestas de nosotras dentro de ello es
decir por qué no también general todo lo
abono orgánico porque no generar darle
esta viabilidad
alternativa a nuestro país a los
pequeños productores darle darle esa
sabiduría con fuerza a nuestras abuelas
a nuestras áreas mientras tanto los
costos en el campo repercuten en la
canasta familiar
390 productos subieron de precio desde
que se inició la guerra siendo los de
mayor alza verduras y hortalizas según
cifras oficiales
maribel rivadeneira antes gastaba cerca
de 7 dólares diarios para cocinar el
almuerzo de su familia ahora paga el
doble y el dinero no le alcanza todo
ahorita está muy caro y qué pasa que los
niños estamos racionando la comida a los
niños y los niños que los niños
solamente te piden te dice mamá tengo
hambre y tú tienes que ver la manera de
darme de comer o buscar la manera de
darles su comida a ellos o no mientras
se ejecutan nuevas medidas para proteger
a los agricultores
leoncio bizarre está montando una
pequeña tienda cambiar de giro es la
única alternativa para defenderse de la
crisis para que su familia pueda tener
sustento complicaba la situación del
alza de los precios en nuestra región o
por cuenta de la guerra la inflación y
también otros y gracias entonces como
siempre por toda la información
económica nos vemos mañana con más y
pasamos ahora a parís